what if I told you that the entire
Chimera antarct was simply a prologue
for something greater and that
everything was being orchestrated by
this blonde mop-headed rat man it was
all very convenient wasn't it an injured
ant Queen appears at just the right
place at just the right time to spawn
just the right King to kill just the
right chairman to trigger just the right
Dark Continent Expedition when it comes
to the Chimera ants we primarily focus
on three key Mysteries those Mysteries
are what where and how and in terms of
what the exact origins of the ant Queen
were never made clear yes Ching informed
us that these ants were from the Dark
Continent however Her Majesty is uh well
she's not quite what she seems during
her short stay in the hunter hunter
series Resort she came to suspect that
even her body contained human DNA
nothing overpowering but a faint trace
of humanity deep within her and even if
the ant Queen hadn't quite literally
said that I think that we would still be
able to pick up on it primarily through
her rather humanoid form Chimera ants
pass on the genetic qualities of their
food so it's clear that their food has
been human at some point but also by the
fact that she is capable of an
intelligent thought and going completely
against ant-based nature she grants a
large degree of freedom to her Squadron
leaders even allowing them individual
names in fact she even felt the need to
name the ant king herself I think
there's a lot more Humanity within the
queen than she would like to admit but
regardless this leads us to two
potential conclusions one is that she is
a breed of chimera ants who consumed
humans on the Dark Continent which isn't
the most ridiculous idea in the world
there was a whole Expedition that
uncovered ancient ruins indicating prior
human life on the constant and Beyond of
the zodiacs is even preparing ancient
language software in the event that they
do encounter native human life but the
second conclusion is that the Chimera
and queen was purpose bread human DNA
was introduced into the species through
assorted sciences that or the much more
basic approach of just feeding cement
some itty bitty human pieces and then
cultivating the perfect breed for the
perfect plan over the course of say I
don't know 50 years it's a very specific
number where did I get that from well to
answer that we first need to establish
how the ant Queen ended up in the center
of Lake Mobius to begin with because a
single ant Traveler from the Dark
Continent to the human realm is like the
equivalent of asking one of our real
life fans to cross the Pacific and
somehow survive it's just not possible
someone was either cursed with the
Chimera ants from an unsuccessful and
undocumented dark consonant voyage that
that does happen or someone purposely
brought the Ant back to the human realm
and I'll tell you who that was in a
second but first this video was
sponsored by naraka the main light
combat Battle Royale game spectacle
featuring fast-paced combat even faster
Pace Mobility with a funky grappling
hook and a wide Ray of male horrific
weapons to choose from niraka is
available through my link in the
description and currently features a 50
discount on Xbox from October 17th to
November 1st and is free with Xbox game
pass naraka has pioneered a unique melee
focused Battle Royale using a
combination of melee weapons and hero
skills to offer Limitless possibilities
in the realm of fight battling it's far
from some simple hack and slash though
in this game it is very necessary to
predict your enemy's next attack and use
the corresponding counter the key to
victory in this game is very much the
philosophy of aha I pretty to your
prediction furthermore each Hero has
their own unique skills like say Takara
who was able to very sneakily steal away
your opponent's weapons plus the
customization of this game is simply
wild allowing you to customize your
character to play as pretty much anyone
or anything you so desire and you can
start playing right now through my link
in the description so go do that thing
but for now it's back to you me someone
was either cursed with the Chimera ants
from an unsuccessful and undocumented
dark consonant voyage that that does
happen or someone purposely brought the
Ant back to the human realm which I find
far more likely considering the awfully
convenient location the queen found
herself in NGL the one place in the
hunter hunter world where a vicious
man-eating ant endemic would be allowed
to cultivate due to their lack of
technology and communication with the
outside world if the ant king had washed
up in any other country in Hunter Hunter
this threat would have been flagged and
exterminated before netro could even
raise a single hand in prayer now to be
fair the ant Queen was heavily injured
when we first encountered her which is
the very least one would expect after
Crossing and apocalyptic ocean however
that injury also forced her to remain in
NGL she wasn't free to roam around and
find a perfect Nest the queen was dying
and needed to pop out a king as soon as
possible and unfortunately after
examining the questions of what where
and how we've answered very little in
fact we've created more questions two
more questions being who and why yes the
Chimera ants could have been a
ridiculous twist of fate a force of
nature finding its way through the
brutal and narrow cracks of life but the
circumstantial evidence is definitely
pointing towards this being a very
calculated maneuver and the culprits
become quite obvious when we look at the
results of the Chimera antarct when you
boil it down two major developments
occurred as a result of these events one
was the death of chairmanetro and the
other was the acquisition of 5000
Chimera and hybrid Soldiers the first
event directly benefiting Beyond netro
and the second benefiting one pariston
Hill and so my hypothesis is this
pariston and Beyond orchestrated the
Chimera Antarctic with the purpose of
removing chairman netro and thus
allowing them to go to the Dark
Continent and with that dear in mind all
of pariston's Prior actions start to
make a pretty terrifying degree of sense
just like his rat namesake pariston has
been a plague on the hunter Association
ever since he first joined he was the
one who instituted the temporary Hunter
system which gradually wrestled power
away from netra he is also heavily
implied for being the one responsible
for a large number of hunters going
missing and during the Chimera antarct
Morrow quite blatantly stated that
paristan was directly hindering the
extermination effort so quite the
naughty naughty boy we have here
although to be fair escrow himself
actually assisted pariston greatly by
granting him absurd amounts of power and
authority and when questioned by beans
about the vice chairman position netro
simply stated I want the hunter who's
most difficult for me to deal with
that's the kind of right-hand man I want
and I found the perfect guy however as
we would soon come to discover Harriston
was secretly working for Isaac naturo's
son Beyond nettera a name that I will
never get over because damn that is one
way to crush your child with
expectations but beyond knew his father
quite well which I imagine is why he
chose Patterson to begin with because
natural hired powerstone for the sake of
a challenge so I imagine that netro
hired paristan knowing that netro would
also hire pariston and thus play
straight into netro's plan wow that's
that's a lot of net arose meanwhile
pariston's role in this this whole
ordeal is something along the lines of
oh you want me to mess with someone I'm
in it's more of a partnership than that
though it became very apparent that
Beyond Trust Paris into a certain degree
to handle things on his end that's why
Beyond could honestly answer that he was
completely unaware of a spy within the
zodiacs because he leaves pariston to
conduct business on his own but always
working towards the same goal and that's
why as soon as netro did pass away Paris
didn't immediately left I mean I say
immediately what he actually did was
leave after doing the political
equivalent of pissing on the floor in
public but the point was that the job
was done and here's how it played out
Beyond netro visited the Dark Continent
50 years ago as part of the kukanyu
Kingdom Voyage there they almost became
the first group to bring back something
beneficial to the human realm but you
know some complications arose the
Expedition went off course and the team
was afflicted with so by the immortality
these which they were promptly cursed
with and brought back however Beyond
brought back a second curse whilst he
was frolicking about on the Dark
Continent he encountered a rather
curious species the Chimera ants a
shockingly dangerous and yet highly
compact threat to which Beyond thinks
LOL fun and he packs his bag with a
souvenir ant or even ants plural I mean
it's probably a bit more complicated
than that because whatever Beyond saw on
the Dark Continent basically governs his
life now he became obsessed with the
science Mass to the point of insanity
but beyond returns Herman daddy netro
says you're grounded not just to Beyond
but to the whole world because it was
after this voyage that he lobbied the V5
to ban Dark Continent travel and most
importantly Isaac sets the condition
that Beyond may only return to the Dark
Continent after he dies and Beyond takes
this condition rather well actually and
goes about plotting his father's ventral
death over the course of the next five
decades Beyond experiments with his aunt
souvenirs infusing them with a faint
trace of human DNA in order to
accelerate things by things I mean the
aspect of human intelligence and then
aptitude required to become the father
murdering King beasts that Beyonds
needed them to be because if he just
releases regular ants in the wild and
all they do is eat a crab or something
then you know we're not going to get
very far they're just gonna keep going
crab crab crab crab which is not very
productive but at some stage Beyond also
recruits paristan who infiltrates the
association giving Beyond easy access to
all of the necessary levels of power and
then just as the kakin Empire is on the
verge of announcing their Dark Continent
Expedition pariston drops off the ant
Queen in NGL he leaves her purposely
injured and on the brink of death to
ensure that she remains within NGO
effectively turning the country into a
controlled farm and just to make things
extra Sinister Paris and sprinkles in a
couple of very appetizing nen uses Paco
ponzu and the other randoms just so
happen to be on an expedition in NGL in
theory hunting for Magical beasts
however ultimately their purpose was for
the Beast to hunt them this jump started
nen use within the ants with the goal of
having them evolve so rapidly that
within a few weeks one of them could
challenge the power of even netra and as
a fortunate Stroke of Luck for parastin
gone in kilowatt also happened to be in
NG all the time and accelerated nenues
by accidentally unlocking remotes Aura
notes and it was only at this point that
the world was alerted to the Chimera and
threat NGL had served its purpose
perfectly as a farm and there was now a
being that required the full force of
the hunter Association to bring down
however pariston would not allow that
full force to be dedicated though and he
said about systematically and
administratively choking chairmanetro
with the intent to make him as
vulnerable as possible during the
Chimera antarct powerstone whilst unseen
both constrained Personnel dedicated to
the extermination and he also withheld
Hunters with relevant abilities because
by this time his political power rivaled
and perhaps even surpassed that of
nettera over the course of three years
he had completely undermined the
association by flooding it with temp
Hunters supporting him and very
suspiciously gradually removing Hunters
who supported netra and by removing I
mean well I mean probably murdering
however the one problem with this plan
as it stands is that yeah sure you can
get rid of nettera but what are you
going to do about the all-powerful and
God that you've created in the process
us well to ensure that neither natural
nor the ant king would be an issue going
forward that's why we landed on the
solution of the Poor Man's Rose no
matter how powerful the ant king was
this bomb was a guaranteed Fail-Safe to
kill him not necessarily through the
explosion but via the toxic aftermath
it's genius absolute terrifying genius
and as a byproduct pariston then
acquired 5 000 then using ants and
popped them in the fridge for later
going a layer deeper breeding a hybrid
ant Army may even have been an essential
part of Beyond in pariston's plans
perhaps requiring this Force for their
mission on the Dark Continent everything
did work out quite conveniently but in
the event that netro did survive there
were also fail safes to ensure that he
was not going to be a problem going
forward pariston's Plan B would have
been quite simple he continues to gather
political power usurping natural's role
as chairman and almost certainly gains
the trust of the V5 due to the fact that
under natural's watch an extinction
level threat was allowed to develop and
came within a prayer away from
annihilating Humanity plus you know all
of those Hunters that have gone missing
over the years under your watchnatural
are bad bad chairman where is I pariston
good chairman and the 5 000 hybrid and
soldiers also would have played a part
in this because it was hypothesized that
paristan could have flooded the
association with them by having them
take the hunter exam and easily securing
the greatest officially licensed and
politically Untouchable army in the
world and in one of the more brutal case
scenarios pariston could have used his
ant Army to kill Nero himself because we
are talking about 5 000 unique nen users
at least one of her a combination of
them is going to have an ability that
netro cannot deal with at the very least
not deal with whilst fighting 4099 other
ads that's not really powerstone's style
though which is why I believe that the
true Plan B was for Beyond netro to take
his father's life which was even a fact
amused upon by mizai storm who suspected
that Isaac Nitro was hoping that Beyond
would come to challenge and kill him one
day which sounds horrible but the
naturals have Vega they have a strange
family Dynamic and the idea is actually
quite touching in their own weird way it
goes a lot deeper than that though
because paristan may have been the
individual to enact the Chimera ant
master plan but that's only one side of
the story this video really didn't go
into a lot of detail regarding Beyond
and what he was doing at the time and
that's because this is only part one all
of this was very much to prepare you for
what's going to happen next because it's
big stuff and here here is a taste
Beyond natural is quite literally
immortal